hello everyone welcome to another
YouTube hang out super excited to be
here with jay from perseverance pays off
with the Mogul dad a new podcast that he
started off when he asked interviewing
for his podcast I said let's give it a
try happy to contribute why don't we
turn into a YouTube hang out so that my
audience could learn from him too so Jay
welcome aboard if you want to just give
the audience a quick overview of what
the podcast is all about and then dive
into how you normally run things in your
questions let's start of the podcast
back in June it was on something about
fish I suffer badly with anxiety so I'm
using it more almost like a therapy but
also trying out people everything's
likes of Straight program unfortunately
there's a lot of bumps and at first I
you can store it with you in business
and what you're trying to do I thought
we had tried to reach oqc come on the
podcast cool well hit me up let's get
into it whatever questions you have
intro I'm muscle is good we say this is
this is this effort by our 10th episode
can you tell us a little bit about
yourself and what you do sure my name is
Evan Carmichael I believe in
entrepreneurs how I have my business I
guess is through my youtube channel for
my website through my books and the
speaking gigs that I do I want people
who want to be entrepreneurs to believe
themselves to chase their dreams and to
not hold themselves back go out and
create companies that change the world
now one corner see you say all the time
leave and um what's the goal of a
million sort so my big goal is to help a
billion entrepreneurs and much more
important than actually reaching that
goal because people say well how do you
measure that is that by youtube fuses up
by newsletter subscribers how are you
going to measure that and I'm actually
not so concerned with measuring it it's
much more about the process I think too
many people set a goal I want to be here
i want to have this car i want to make
this amount of money i want to whatever
it is that you set a goal and I will do
all this crap to get there that's how
most people set goals where for me you
got to enjoy the work that you're doing
like the work is the goal doing
meaningful work should be what matters
and yes that will help you get two
different spots but if you are spending
your life doing stuff that you hate just
to get some other goal that's not the
way to have massive success so if you
look at the people who are truly
successful they love the work they're
doing so I'm not so attached to the
1,000,000,000 goal the point of that was
to help me do things that play a bigger
game so if I want to reach that many
people it's not going to be by doing
one-on-one consulting right it's going
to be by having a YouTube channel by
doing the book deal by doing a lot of
speaking by getting out there and making
a bigger name and so that's what kind of
drives me is much more the impact I want
to do things that have a great impact on
the entrepreneur community and look like
myself like a big Zynga and I not preach
for this is pure so finish pays off with
you it's believed he does a little bit
of belief yeah belief for me comes from
one believing in yourself I think that's
how most people see believe is
self-confidence right that comes from my
parents when you know they would always
tell me that I was a cast rlly
Carmichael my mom's last name is Miss
Julie and I could do anything I wanted
to so they kind of instilled that sense
of belief in myself and I try to pass
that on to to my son as well is now
seven but it's more than just self
confidence for me it's also believe in
what you're doing so have passion for
the work that you do right like you're
starting this podcast you know you have
an intent to help people you love
ideally the people that you're bringing
onto the show a lot of people don't love
the work that they do right ninety
percent of people wake up and drop to a
job that they hate so you need to
believe in the work that you're doing
have passion for it and then believe
that it's going to work out and have the
conviction to follow through you know
perseverance the title of this show
following through on the things you say
you're going to do and doing it
consistently not just one time once a
week whatever but consistently following
through on the things that you said
you're going to do so for me belief is a
self-confidence it's the passion and
it's a conviction to follow through now
through through with what you started
the character premiership and also ended
what are the mistake challenges of
you had and what you want from him to
get rid of today there's been so many
failures that I don't even remember I
think people are so attached to failure
that people think it's like if I fail
then then that's it I'm done for where
people fail their way to success like
I've learned them become successful
through all the failures that have
happened to me along the way I think the
one of the biggest ones early on in my
career my first business was trying to
do everything myself you know I didn't
think to go out and model success you
know I had a software company I was
trying to sell software and I was just
sucking it was making three hundred
dollars a month and not surviving in
feeling really low and feeling that I
had no self-worth and I was working like
I was persevering man I'd like it wasn't
i wasn't slacking off I was grinding it
out and I wasn't getting results and
it's cuz I was trying to do everything
myself and when I said you know what I'm
not the first guy I try to sell software
before and I looked at Microsoft and
Bill Gates and how we got started I
modeled what worked for him and up to my
business to help me grow and so I've had
a lot of success in modeling other
people you know my office I have
successful people that inspired me from
my parents to other entrepreneurs and
visionaries and I used their success cuz
we don't always have a great environment
like maybe your parents haven't done
what you want to do maybe your friends
don't have as big a dream as you do and
if you keep only listening to them
you're going to stay exactly where you
are and so surround yourself with people
who have done more who are reaching from
or who have bigger dreams have bigger
visions that's important and I didn't do
enough of that early on in my life and
when I started doing that it had a huge
impact on my personal development as a
human being as well as my business
success now what did you find like say
the biggest thing when I learned and
like they lost only three weeks I've
doing it this far I mean you recommend
out for everybody you cut it a little
bit the last three weeks what is it that
you recommend for everybody like you say
yeah finding a mentor to London from
yeah absolutely i think i got when i was
getting started uh my parents did a
fantastic job of being my human mentor
like teaching me how to be a good human
being giving me values but they didn't
know much about business it just wasn't
their background so they did didn't tell
me you know when I said hey why what
should I give about business and say
well invest in bank stocks you know just
didn't have the knowledge to give me
about being an entrepreneur and that's
totally cool but they gave me the
foundation uh I went to a bank to try to
find the mentor you know I'm went to
bank is the entrepreneur like this is
how little I knew I walked into a bank
and asked the bank manager I'd like some
help to grow my business cuz you know
Bank supposed to be the Friends of
entrepreneurs right and he said well do
you need a loan like well i don't know i
don't i don't think so but i don't know
i just need i need a mentor i need help
i don't i don't know what to do in my
company so well that's not really what
we do here at the bank is like oh okay
great so yeah it's definitely a struggle
finding that first mentor and and the
people have also helped me this
definitely the traditional mentors that
I've had a number of them in my life but
also the aspirational mentors like I
said the people in my office I can learn
something from people who have had
success whether it's steve jobs or
howard schultz are Richard Branson or EP
Giannini or whoever it is and pull
something from them not to be like my
goal is not to be the next Steve Jobs
and I shouldn't be the gold front of
your listeners it's to be the best
version of yourself and you can pull
something that Steve Jobs did that
Howard Schultz did that Richard Branson
did to make you a better entrepreneur to
make you a better person and so I call
those aspirational mentors and I think
we focus a lot on the one-on-one mentors
people you can sit down and you know
meet for coffee and and that can
definitely help and it's helped me in my
career but a lot of people ignore the
aspirational mentorship you all never
meet Steve Jobs it's not possible maybe
in the next life but as long as I'm on
you know in this life I will never meet
steve jobs but I've learned a lot from
him and I consider him to be one of my
mentors
now for the successfully and now where a
user agent to just say hello you're
right I think once you have success it's
easier to get complacent I think a lot
of entrepreneurs get boring did they get
bored like you happens a lot with with
entrepreneurs you leave a job because
you hate it because you don't wanna be
boxed in I don't want to work for the
man I don't be boxed in so you're going
to start your own company and its total
creative freedom at the start and then
you find some customers and then you
start working towards something that you
that works but often that success
becomes chains for future growth you
boxed yourself in of how to run a
business and it's super hard to break
out of it to do something else and so
for me I have a situation where you know
a lot of the people in my life a lot of
my friends still that I meet regularly
here in Toronto that I love is human
beings they can't give me be this
motivation and advice because I've done
more because they look at me and say wow
when you've done such a great job with
that bulk or that youtube channel or
whatever and I appreciate it but i also
don't need it right like I want like I
want something to challenge me I want
somebody this happen you know you've
done a good job but uh it's just ok
liked you should be playing that way
bigger game so I'm going to bust me up a
little bit and so I get that a lot
through the ice nation low mentors I do
it on my youtube channel where we do a
you know I do a daily top 10 video
series on my channel or take lessons
from a successful entrepreneur Elon Musk
or whoever it is and I did that
selfishly for me because I want to be
around Elon Musk and I may never meet
him but I want to hang around him
digitally as much as I can and hopefully
some of his ideas and mindsets and way
of thinking rub off on the me that
changed my perception of the world and
every day we do a different successful
person whether it's an entrepreneur an
athlete a musician inventor whatever it
is and that helps create a better
environment at least for me to continue
to stretch myself and make me want to do
more because if i look at Elon Musk
I've done nothing compared to Elon Musk
right like zero I'm a tiny speck not
even on the map and so you know looking
at these guys who I may never reach that
potential but looking at them and seeing
how they do things inspires and
motivates me to want to do more when the
people around you may be saying that
I've already done a lot and so I find
that super helpful and I worked only a
couple Joey and get to be and you asked
him about people and family around
saying that he'll support way what you
do not you like the person doing that in
an entrepreneur say what but you're
picking on that one yeah I've been
fortunate in that I have people in my
life who are supportive of me even
though they can't give me advice you
know my parents always you know they
always believed in me they always told
me I could do whatever I want and I I
believe that myself but they can never
tell me exactly what I wanted to do and
I have two siblings and the three of us
have all gone in totally different
directions from each other and from our
parents were all our own enigmas and I
credit my parents were helping helping
us and kind of encourage ourselves and
not follow in our parents footsteps um
that being said so like I'm fortunate
you know that doesn't mean that's that's
why I'm successful and and I'm you know
I can't take accountability for me being
more successful right you know i'm i'm
i'm canadian i consider that to be a
good thing you know others who are from
other countries you know they don't have
the same resources and opportunities as
as Canadians do but you can still be
successful a lot of people blame the
lack of parental support the lack of
being in the right country the lack of
government support lack of an
educationally I can't be successful
because I didn't go to Harvard or
whatever my parents didn't have enough
money to send me here or you know our
parents weren't entrepreneurs so you
know I won't be successful I never had
anybody I knew growing up take
accountability like just because you
haven't had the resources before it
doesn't mean that you can't use the
resources that you have
right now and more importantly be
resourceful enough to go off and want to
create something so having people around
you that support you is important and if
you don't have that right now don't let
that be your story for the rest of your
life so your parents didn't support you
okay what are you going to do that you
like so for the next 40 years of your
life you're just going to whine and
complain that your parents and support
you at some point you have to take
accountability for your own life and say
I'm going to create an environment that
supports me being the greatest meet with
us listen to your podcast watching
YouTube shows going out and making new
friends reading books and inspire you in
right you have to take accountability
and responsibility for your own life you
know if you're eight years old okay
maybe not but if you're a grown-ass man
you got to go and take accountability
for your life and stop blaming the
circumstances because as long as you
blame those other people those other
things it's never my fault such that
guy's fault their fault right as long as
you're blaming them your life is never
going to change now what motivates you
the most want to put your feet on the
floor every morning for me its impact
it's knowing that I'm helping
entrepreneurs it's sometimes it's hard
like in the early days it was hard I
would make a video and nobody watches it
all right or even before videos I would
be speaking and I would love speaking
gigs and engaging with the audience but
then it might be a month or two months
or six months between these speaking
engagements oh how do I stay kind of
motivated in between what i would do
from that is i would take some of the
emails that people sent me and i would
put it together in this powerpoint slide
show that i watched every morning to
kind of remind myself that I'm having an
impact that the things that I'm doing is
changing people's lives even in some
small way now I'm fortunate that I get
that from my youtube channel is that you
know we've got people live streaming
watching we've got you know listening
afterwards on my youtube channel and you
can see the comments come in and knowing
that excites me and keep you motivated
and I know I have a responsibility to go
and help others but that's fortunate
where I'm at now because of the moment
built up but again in the early days I
didn't have it so I had to create it for
myself where I made that PowerPoint
slide show that I would watch every
morning to kind of remind myself because
it's so easy right like you have a great
day you land a big client you go to some
event you hear some speaker you listen
to the perseverance pays off podcast you
get all jazzed up and inspired and the
next day like poof it's gone look where
was the guy who is all motivated
yesterday and so instead of randomly
listening to some podcasts on one day
that inspires you make that part of your
daily routine right like perseverance
pays off motivates you and that comes
out once a week then every Tuesday
morning you're setting your schedule to
go listen to the episode to remind
myself to persevere and then monday
wednesday thursday friday i'm doing
something else like designing an
environment that whatever works for you
in terms of motivation everybody kind of
takes a different way but whatever works
for you design that into your
environment daily because even if you
are super high motivated yesterday at
least for me it's often just gone the
next day I need to start from scratch
every single day now after this point
explosive that's probably the best
recertified that you've ever seen um
best piece of advice I've received this
probably from my parents which was just
to do what I'm passionate about to do
what excites me to do what I love and to
explore if I don't know like my parents
were the kind of people who would drive
me around when I was young to do
baseball card shows you know 92 93 Blue
Jays World Series that was a thing so
I'm 12 13 years old I'm even just before
that I was out buying cards selling cars
going to trade shows I'm this you know
eleven-year-old trying to make deals
with 45 year old guys on cards nickel
and diming them serious like ten cents
off on a deal and they would drive me
all over there because they wanted to
encourage me to follow my passion even
if they like they didn't understand
baseball cards they had no interest in
baseball cards they didn't understand
why I had to line up and wait overnight
at some places and taking the spring
training every year to get autographs of
Roberto
on Joe Carter and all these guys so you
know I've tried to follow that through
for everything that I do that if if you
wake up and you are not looking forward
to what you're going to do today for too
many days in a row something has to
change like life is not perfect crap
will happen you don't enjoy every single
part of your job but if you're waking up
day after day after day and looking self
in the mirror and saying man I I'm not
looking forward to today you got to
change your life you got to do something
that you are passionate about and so
I've tried to ride that through and it's
been super helpful for me and if you
create at least say so after not after a
point it's not work anymore it's
something yeah you're joining me yeah
and this you know this is the time of
thinking when do I quit right some
people say never quit don't quit never
give up um and and I agree if you are
still passionate what you're doing like
you need to persevere as long as you
still love the crap because maybe you
need to get better I like maybe you're
just not good enough I what you do yet
you know maybe you need you want to be
an NHL hockey player maybe you got to
get on the ice and take more practice
shots and be there at five in the
morning and drill and skate like just
because you know that's your dream if
you're just going once a week it's never
going to happen you gotta you gotta
persevere and drive through but if you
don't love it anymore if you're dreading
it you know it was just okay then that's
the time to quit that's the time to go
on and move there's something else so
for me that's always a gut check as long
as I'm loving what I'm doing then I will
keep finding a way to make it work and
just try again and try again and
persevere and keep going but if I've
lost the love and this okay sometimes
you start something and maybe that day
you lose the love maybe in a year you
lose the love but once you lose the love
if that happens then you owe it to
yourself to quit even if you had some
success at it and go chase something
else even if you don't know what that
something else is yet because staying
where you are right now and something
that's just mediocre is never going to
let you become the greatest you one
question I
I've heard you mention it what's your
thoughts on snapchat uh I'm not a huge
snapchat user um the couple reasons one
I don't like hell things disappear and
yes you can download them and yes you
can upload them to youtube or whatever
you want to do afterwards and and I'm
not massively into the vlogging style
yet so I haven't figured out how to
story tell in a way that works best for
me there's definitely a lot of audience
there I think people are under
estimating it a lot I think people think
it's just for kids where it's not as
there's a lot of grown-ups on there too
and a lot of your market could be on
there I think if you are thinking about
video and you don't have the resources
to make a good quality product on a
YouTube video snapchats an easy way to
get started I recently acquired Toronto
dance also which is the largest salsa
dance school in North America and i want
the owner or I'm new and I want they the
manager that I brought in to do video
and so I gave him a snapchat account
like a set up a snapchat account and I
want you three times a day to be
snapping away from Jonathan salsa
because we haven't reached the point
where proven video would be a good
investment a hire a team to come on and
do full-time kind of YouTube videos
there so he's snapping away and he's
he's having a great time and he's
getting some interest and it's helping
the business so I'm a fan I just not I
haven't figured out the use for me I
feel like it's maybe still a little too
early um for me I like to come into
something that's already like massive
and then just use my content to dominate
where I feel what snapchat it's too hard
to explore at the moment there's no way
to find people except by name so people
are promoting it through Twitter through
their newsletter on their on their
website so i will likely get on there
and in a bigger way just not yet now one
question people always hate do you have
any regrets uh
I don't know I don't spend a lot of time
thinking about it um I almost did and
and I guess that's you know the biggest
decision ever had to make in my life the
hardest decision was when I was in my
last few University and I was thinking
about going for these high paying jobs
that I thought I always wanted six
figures traveling around the world all
the you know things that you're say yet
you want and then I had an opportunity
to work as an owner at the software
company that wasn't making any money and
I had a really hard time trying to
figure out what I would want to do and
the thing that helped me through was I
imagined myself kind of on my deathbed
looking back and thinking will I regret
this well I regret saying no and going
for this job and I thought I would like
if I didn't try this out I thought I
would regret it and so that was the last
thing that kind of pushed me over to say
okay I'm going to go in and give it a
shot it doesn't work I can always go
back and get one of these jobs and ever
since then I've used that as a proxy to
figure out all the big important
decisions in my life well I regret
saying no or saying yes to this and if I
feel like I will regret it than I have
to go I have to I have to give it a try
and so i'm sure i have a bunch of little
regrets like you know I don't know did I
buy my flowers doing by my wife flowers
yesterday no maybe I should regret that
you know could have been nicer to
somebody in the elevator and say hi to
them or something right like sure
there's all these little things in life
that you can you can be the
monday-morning quarterback and analyze
and say I could have done that better
with terms of major things there's
nothing that that I regret and I'm glad
that I kind of discovered that framework
when I did because I needed it and I
almost made a huge is a huge mistake in
my life now what's your definition of
Nina / careers perseverance to me is
just keep going is keep going when
people tell you it's not going to work
out when you dealt yourself when all you
see is darkness around you when there's
no light at the end of the time
all but you just feel it like it's in
you like I need to get this out I need
to keep going it's something
inexplicable I think you can force
yourself to do something that you don't
like for for so long until you reach a
breaking point but when it's when you
love something that you have to find a
way to keep going even when it doesn't
make logical sense to anybody like
friends and family sure but like even to
yourself why am I doing this I don't
know I love it I have to find a way to
keep going that's perseverance to me you
keep going on it when you love it even
though it may not make sense because
when it makes sense to everybody
supports you it's easy I don't know if I
would call that perseverance write it
like it's it's so much easier it's when
it's hard it's when you're not getting
results is when you know you're you're
working 16 hours a day or whatever it is
you're pouring everything you've got
into it and you don't know if it's going
to work out that to me is perseverance
that's what best way for today my fans
to not a minister to go to the find me
ah easiest way just to look you know
look up Evan Carmichael you'll find me
my website YouTube channel it's where I
live mostly is on my youtube channel
Twitter but that's prolly this way
whatever whatever method they like using
you can just search heaven comical and
you can find me I've actually got a
quote on my desk that is highly relevant
let me let me pull it up I got it here
Calvin Coolidge president of the united
states that nobody knows about we got it
up here uh nothing in this world can
take the place of persistence you know
this one this is a good one nothing this
place can take the oil persistence
talent will not nothing is more common
than unsuccessful people with talent
genius will not unrewarded genius is
almost a proverb educational not the
world is full of educated derelicts
persistence and determination alone are
omnipotent the slogan press on has
solved and always will solve the
problems of the human race
that's perseverance to me oh I can't
thank you enough Evan and hopefully we
can do this again cool look forward to
the show man and keep me posted thank
you